I'm a behaviorist by training so I'm
interested in understanding the
evolution of behavior and Al monkeys are
my
expertise they are found from the forest
the tropical forest of Panama in Central
America down to the northern portion of
Argentina in every country except the
guanas the only volume on Al monkeys was
done 30 years ago 1994 it was published
and so I knew that at some point I
wanted to bring all of our research on
Al monkeys in a synthesis in an edited
volume and in fact most of the 60
authors in the book are from countries
where the Alm monis range alms are the
only ones the only primates in the
Americas that have nocturnal habits the
Almani lives in small groups what we
call monogamous groups the male and the
female establish a pair bond they only
reproduce with each other and when the
infants are born the father is one of
the most amazing father in the living
[Music]
world